on va le faire rentrer c'est Jérémy com
en fait c'est lui regardez ce qu'il fait
il donne plein de leçons au Miss en fait
ça pour qu'elle voilà le maintien
exactement vous aviez un coach de bonne
manière à l'époque non on en avait pas
vous en avez pas besoin on avait juste
une chorégraphe qui nous apprenait à
nous tenir droite à marcher faire les
chorégraphies on nait pas de coach non
ou bah maintenant ils ont elles ont même
un coou voilà ça nous coûte de l'oseille
mais bon vouz regarde je ne voulais pas
commencer comme ça mais enchanté ça ne
se dit pas il y a une semaine vous étiez
en famille avec vos copains au McDo dans
une brasserie dans un kebab mais quand
vous allez rentrer quoi qu'il arrive
dans vos régions vous allez être Miss
France là je suis très inquiet sur 10
d'entre vous effectivement j'étais
persuadé qu'on vous avvez coupé les
mains déjà on ne souffle jamais sur son
potage pour le refroidir je voudrais que
devant nous tous vous mangiez ces ces
fruits mais avec vos
couverts vous êtes dans une fanfare norm
désolé on aime beaucoup Jérémy co mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas par des copers
non plus on dirait que non mais c'est
vrai j'adore il non mais le public est
en feu merci Jérémy on est très content
de te recevoir mais n rajoutez pas non
plus non mais c'est vrai l'autre là le
chauffeur de salle la Lyonel non mais
sans déconner non mais franchement il
est pas applaudir on dirait qu'on avait
German Jackson bon Jérémy merci d'être
là merci à vous non ça me fait plaisir
il faut un diplôme pour être coach en
bonnne manière des bonnes manières il
faut un diplôme pas de diplôme pourut
avoir un peu de connaissance sur
l'éducation et les codes mais comment
vous les avez eu vous les bah j'ai des
bons parents non c'est vrai ouais j'ai
des bons parents et puis j'ai j'ai
potassé un peu mon dossier quand même
quand je me suis intéressé parce que à
connaître les codes c'est une chose mais
on peut vivre très heureux sans les
maîtriser voilà en revanche savoir d'où
ça vient et pourquoi ça existe ça c'est
la nuance moi qui m'intéresse c'est de
transmettre la connaissance entre
guillemets d'accord donc vous vous êtes
vous avez toujours baigné là-dedans un
peu dans le lac exactement dans le lac
de
com voilà ça c'est fait
non mais c'est c'est votre c'est votre
métier en fait bah pas que je suis aussi
directeur de la communication d'un
magazine dans l'art qui s'appelle bzard
magazine ah ouaard j'adore vous abonne
si vous voulez j'adore ce magazine c'est
incroyable et et sinon je donne pas mal
de cours c'est vrai on dans des
entreprises dans les cabinets d'avocat
et voilà parce que les gens ont envie de
mais c'est-à-dire que malheureusement ou
heureusement moi j'ai envie de dire
c'est que qui peut le plus peut le moins
donc plus on connaît les codes moins on
est un peu singularisé dans des dîners
ou dans des choses comme ça parce qu'en
plus les codes à table c'est le moment
où on est tous en train de se regarder
les uns les autres et on a plutôt
tendance l'être humain dit plutôt
toujours à quelqu'un j'ai entendu parler
de toi en mal que j'ai entendu parler de
toi en bien donc du coup autant limiter
la casse ça vaok non ça va ça va j'ai
donc c'est quoi les les deux trois
conseils là quand on est à table et bien
les conseils c'est que d'abord on on
attend quand jusqu'à 8 personnes on
attend que la personne qui vous invite
et commencer à déjeuner ou à dîner à
partir de 8 on peut ne pas attendre ah
ouais d'accord voilà donc ça c'est un pe
combien là bon c'est bon on est neu
vas-y ramène le ramène le ragou là non
mais c'est bon il y a des questions que
je trouve plutôt pourquoi l'un ver d'eau
doit être rempli avant que les invités
ne passent à table par exemple c'est
quoi pourquoi pour les médicaments bravo
Pascal quoi pour ceux qui doivent
prendre des médicaments que ça se fasse
discrètement qui demande pas de l'eau
pour pouvoir prendre leur médicament
onattire pas l'attention effectivement
sur la maladie tu as V C comment PASC
tour Pascal de la tour du pain JIC
Pascal de la tour du ouais non je peux
dire là là conna on conna là tu as
trouvé à qui parler là hein hein quand
ils mangent ensemble sans déconner à
force de s'attendre il à 20h il mangent
à minuit frère attends tu as fait le
verre d'eau attend mais sans déconner
c'est bon manger oui question galanterie
est-ce qu'il est vrai que quand on
invite une meuf au resto une pas une
meuf oua déjà JEE FEM une jeune femme ou
une femme est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas lui tenir la porte et rentrer
d'abord pour des mesures de sécurité
exactement c'est-à-dire que l'homme
précède la femme au restaurant c'est le
seul lieu public alors ça les temps ont
évolué au départ c'est c'était pour voir
si l'endroit n'était pas un endroit
malsin malfamé et aujourd'hui c'est pour
que les regards ne se posent pas sur la
femme mais sur l'homme c'est le seul
lieu public bravo et dans l'escalier
aussi pardon si je puux me permettre
vous pouvez non c'est ça ouais dans
l'escalier on doit passer dev ouais pour
pas regarder les fesses de la meuf oui
mais alors ça oui mais ça ça a évolué
c'est-à-dire qu'autrefois quand les
femmes ne portaient que des jupes on
laissait la femme derrière l'homme mais
aujourd'hui pour vous retenir parce
qu'on est là pour vous protéger ou
protéger la personne la plus faible ça
c'est ça si vous êtes on
attend si vous êtes avec votre
grand-père par exemple si vous estimez
qu'il est plus faible laissez-le passer
devant parce que vous allez le retenir
ça dépend de l'héritage aussion alors on
parle pas d'argent normalement l'éritage
c'est fou ça c'est fou et et donc donc
les miss vous leur apprenez quoi à faire
les miss c'est ce que j'ai tendance à
dire c'est que une fois qu'on est élu
Miss ou qu'on retourne dans sa région on
passe du kebab je me répète mais à des
déjeuners ou des dîners avec avec tout
le protocole et des élus et à table
elles ne savent pas ces jeunes filles
elles ont 18 élus il mangent aussi
parfois très mais bien sûr mais
justement comme ell sont Miss France ou
Dauphine je leur dis représenté et ça
les intéresse parce que ces momentsl les
stressent vraiment c'est pour ça qu'ells
m'ont appelé monsieur bonne manière et
qu'il m'envoie des petit SMS en me
disant ce soir j'ai un rendez-vous
comment je fais ah ouais c'est vrai ou
est-ce qu'on a on peut manger beaucoup
au restaurant quand on est avec des des
gars tout ça des genscoup important
ouais ça se fait ou pas bah c'estàd que
normalement seinf on seinfre pas et surt
si on est avec d'A comment j'en ai rien
à
cararimur mais il faut aussi le faire
par rapport à sa propre faim et par
rapport à qui on est c'est est-ce que
c'est poli si quelqu'un on mange en face
de quelqu'un il dit pousse-toi moi je
veux pas que tu manges à côté de moi
décale-toi mange pas en face de moi
c'est poli ça ou pas alors ça sent le
vécu c'est quand même pas très bien pas
bien la situation est un peu complexe
parce que si jamais vous avez choisi de
déjeuner avec quelqu'un normal il te
décale en
diagonal tu manges pas tu déjeunes ou tu
dines je déjeune ouais personne dit ça
çarive ça c'est c'est grave ça ou pas
bah moi j'ai jamais vécu ça mais faut
changer
[Rires]
d'Amok pas déjeuné tu pas déjeuné en
face de
quelqu'un déjà un mec ne mange pas en
face de moi une jeune fille oui une
fille oui j'ai confiance parce qu'elle
du pas mangé d'ailleurs tu as même pas
mangé en face de moi on éta à côté ouis
ouais mant tu étais là et j'étais là
onta pas elle a pas mangé en face vois
mais c'est vrai que je je dis je dis la
dernière fois je mangeais avec un
pote tu dis tu te mets là mets-toi en
face mets-toi en diagonal à la même
table quand même oui mais non mais lui
moi je veux que là ce soit comme ça qui
se met mais vous avez peur de quoi vous
avez peur de cche
énormément les gens crache c'estis ce
que je fais moi je mets des bouteilles
comme ça je mets comme un truc je te
jure c'est vrai il me disent qu'est-ce
que vous voulez voir je dis vous me
mettez une très grande bie une très
grande é une très grande vitelle et je
les mets commass en parfu ple de FL
ouais c'est pour ça en parfu tu as vu tu
as pas marqué
ouais donc je les mets toutes ça comme
ça en parfu et les mecs et les mecs et
les mecs vous savez que moi moi il
m''est arrivé la dernière fois je mangé
avec un grand patron de chaîne et je
vois il me parle beaucoup quand j'ai
c'est bon c'est bon tu me raconteras ça
une fois que tu auras fini c'est vrai tu
veux me raconter tout maintenant tu me
raconteras ça après t'inquiète pas on a
le temps des débris hein ouais ouais un
jour il y a un gars il m'aenvoyé une
TEPA entière
entière et moi je vous envoie une salade
une fois lui lui mais tu sais que lui
j'ai mangé avec lui bruti là salade
césar complète ouis il rigol je suis
parti du restaurant oui je suis parti ou
pas oui laèce s tu me fais chier allez
pourquoi je m'envis je suis parti César
vous avez découpé de parmesonti quelle
horreur c'est un por sauvage en
liberté mais je te
jure je te jure J je te jure c'est
horrible oui coach quand on a fini de
déjeuner ou de dîner est-ce qu'on doit
laisser ses couverts que d'un côté sur
la table exactement on met les couverts
à 16h20 16h202 le Coutau ette et la
fourchette les dent vers le ciel quoi
16h20 16h20 c'est on prend l'assiette on
se dit que c'est un cadrant et on les
met à 16h2 si jamais vous retournez la
fourchette ça veut dire que pour ceux
qui font le service vous avez encore
envie qu'on vous propose vous avez
encore faim si quelqu'un si quelqu'un a
un gros morceau de salade entre les
dents par exemple comment ça se passe
est-ce qu'il faut lui dire ou est-ce
qu'il faut comment comment vous
organisez moi je dit ça fois j'éta avec
un gars si jeire tuas un arbuste
là une de truc alors souvent quand on
fait ça en face de quelqu'un
la personne a tendance à vous imiter et
si jamais elle vous imite pas vous lui
dites c'est gênant tuas un petit trucuc
comm un gros un truc qui est hyper fort
en restaurant faites-le c'est génial
j'adore je fais regarde e tu as un truc
sur le front là et le gars se gratte
toujours le mon faites-le c'est génial
c'est ça pas obligé d'être restant c'est
génial ouis je fais pas je le fais pas
c'est génial un petiting comme ça qui
vaut ce qui vaut mais qui est assez
sympa oui des petites expressions oui
des petites expressions genre qu'il faut
un peu banir bon appétit au plaisir bon
appétit au plaisir enchanté à vos à vos
souit pardon on dit jamais bon appétit à
quelqu'un parce qu'il y a deux
connotations il y en a qui diront que
c'est parce que genre bon courage bon
appétit genre si tu savais comment
cuisine mal ou comment il cuisine mal et
sinon ça fait référence à la digestion
et je m'arrêterai là donc dire bon
appétit c'est comme si vous disiez à
quelqu'un bon intestin grê
quoi et on dit jamais à vos souhaits non
plus alors qu'on a tendance à le faire
parce qu'on on ne met jamais accent sur
la maladie de quelqu'un si jamais vous
éternuez vous allez évidemment vous
excuser et là je vais vous dire je vous
en prie mais en revanche je dis pas la
personne doit pas me le dire parce que
peut-être que personne n'aura remarqué
que je suis malade pas remarqué et si
quelqu'un é tern parce ça ça arrive
parfois vraiment à répétition vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup carrément
après c'est gênant on fait quoi genre on
attend bah on attend lui surtout
peut-être qu'il faudit qu'il aille le
médecin il faut faire une pirouette
l'humour vraiment aider quand on sait
pas quoi faire en terme de bonne manière
de savoir vivre c'est vrai que c'était
drôle ça ouais merci comment je me suis
pris une tacle c'est pas c'est une Amien
amen tac ou et ouais tu tu le calmes
avec
jéréy une question sur
l'additionadition bonne question ça
c'est un vrai sujet de crevard ça
question le crevard
le est-ce que ça reste une bonne manière
de payer systématiquement quand on d
nous déjeune avec une femme ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça paraît un peu sexiste
de refuser si elle propose c'estàd que
ça dépend ça dépend de la situation
professionnellement un homme peut se
laisser inviter par une femme si c'est
elle qui à l'initiative du déjeuner ou
du rendez-vous femme payer dans cadre
professionnel dans un cadre personnel
l'élégance voudrait que l'homme pai mais
on est en
2023 tout le monde se bat pour l'égalité
et il y a parfois des femmes déjà dans
l'amitié qui ont plus de moyens qu'un
homme il y a aussi l'intelligence du
cœur et des moyens qu'il faut faut pas
FIF c'est moyen là quand même c'est
vraiment moyen et je trouve que ça gâche
presque même entre potes ça peut gâcher
un déjeuner ou un dîner et je préfère
moi le payer plutôt que de me fâcher a
quelqu'uni je préfère fâcher
rien à moi je préfère vraiment me
fâcher oui oui si on a droit à un plat
en sauce absolument délicieux il reste
de la sauce dans l'assiette est-ce qu'on
a le droit de prendre un morceau de pain
et de
saucé la règle vous sa c'est
TR alors saucé n'est pas trompé on ne
sauce jamais avec son morceau de pain et
la main on peut saucer éventuellement
avec sa fourchette on pique le morceau
de pain mais on ne rend pas sa ser sa
serviette son assiette comme si elle
était déjà passée au lave-isselle comme
si le chien l'avait léché toujours
parce que ça ça voudrait
direavant ou pas bon ou pas assez
copieux donc du coup pour une fois qu'il
a quelque chose de bon pendant le
déjeuner on y va à fond tu SAU tu Saces
tu sauces toi mais moi j'arrête pas de
saucer moi c'est je peux pas laisser une
assiette sans l'avoir saucé tu saues
hiver comme était moi je sauce hiver
matin soir tout le temps ou faisoi
plaisir juste comme ça comme ça a priori
Jérémy qui est pour vous le le
chroniqueur qui qui semble avoir
meilleur manière c'est qui ça pe êre
Delphine
ça dépend il y a les bonnes manières à
table il y a les bonnes manières dans la
vi comme ça comme ça vasy comme ça voilà
mais je pense
que quoi qui vous inspire le plus tout
le monde se tient droit c'est B je je
parce que c'est quand même une question
pas de milieu mais d'éducation je pense
que Pascal a peut-être eu les codes plus
proches de toutes ces codes là et encore
c'est le nom de son mari elle s'appelle
Pascal Lalou elle en vrai r moi c'est ma
cousine frère qu'est tu races c'est son
mari qui s'appit de la tour du pas elle
s'appelle Pascal benrit
[Applaudissements]
frère mangé des Mar il encore 10 p j'éis
malade ou quoi dismoi et je pense que
Guillaume doit être assez éduqué à
tableén n'importe quoi m avec ses pieds
P on VO pas ses mains normalement il
faut toujours mettre les mains sur la
table France on doit avoir les mains
effectivement parce que ça veut dire
qu'on cache pas d'armes bien ah ouais
voilà je dire et le et le le moins cel
qui sont le moins c'est compliqué là
allez-yy Sophie m'a reprise là donc je
pense que y a un petit VO c'est vra que
sopune
éducation mais la mauvaise éducation je
trouve que c'est une nuance qui que
j'aime pas vraiment parce que on a tous
les codes de notre univers de notre
milieu aussia pas leses de Syx je
suisésoléen sopie elle la classe ah ouis
Jola on dirait une
princesse elle aurait pu être Miss
France d'ailleurs ou pour l'instant ça a
été pris la placeté pris et Delphine
quand même a été Miss France c'est oui
non mais Delphine moi je les ai pas
appris les bonnes manières moi je suis
ici une famille elle pte à table une
famille paysane et tout j'ai pas du tout
appris les Bonn manièrees oui mais il y
a le bon pour le coup il y a beaucoup de
règles et de codes qui viennent de la
France ruralepul populaire et et souvent
on dit il y a une expression qui dit le
bon sens agricole et le bon sens non
mais après dans l'éducation il y aussi
le fait c'est bon j'ai plus le temps là
B qui m'attend beau que j'aisas bah
dis-le et après non j'allais dire ce ce
qui est beau c'est voilà c'est le fait
d'inviter les gens c'est le fait d'aimer
les gens c'est ça aussi pour moi le fa
laisser le saucer lui et puis on verra
après
merci continue à saucer là ça